y lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
hablar acerca de los procesos que hacen
que la vida sea tal como la conocemos y
esencialmente podemos llamar a esto
metabolismo
me
está
mismo
y esto es la toma de energía en
diferentes formas y su descomposición en
sus elementos más fundamentales y luego
su reconstrucción en formas que
encontremos útiles energéticamente
útiles o estructuralmente útiles de modo
que podamos vivir nuestras vidas podamos
crecer podamos reproducir nos podamos
responder a nuestro entorno el
metabolismo y vamos a ver un montón de
ejemplos de esto el metabolismo se
compone principalmente de dos procesos
diferentes
está la descomposición de las sustancias
para obtener energía o componentes
estructurales en la que volvemos a los
componentes básicos ya esto lo llamamos
catabolismo
acá está lo mismo
así que esta es la ruptura de sustancias
y una vez que hemos roto las sustancias
estamos listos para reconstruir las en
formas que no son útiles y llamamos a
esto anabolismo
anna bosch
mismo
y una manera de pensar en ello es
imaginar que alguien construye algo con
legos y tú también quieres construir
algo con legos bueno podrías ir a esos
legos deshacer la construcción y tomar
las piezas de lego individuales y luego
con eso construir la forma que quieras y
puede ser que ni siquiera tengas que ves
hacerlo hasta llegar a las piezas
básicas del ego puede haber estructuras
en ese primer castillo del ego que fue
construido que te pueden resultar útiles
así que vamos a pensar en cómo todo esto
se inicia y lo que es interesante es que
todo esto empezó en las estrellas de las
reacciones de fusión en las estrellas y
esta de aquí es una imagen de una
estrella y una estrella que no sé es muy
familiar
este es el sol y probablemente sepas que
el sol es sólo una de varias estrellas
que han participado en la vida como la
conocemos el sol es nuestra fuente más
directa de energía para la mayor parte
de la vida tal como la conocemos hay
algunas bacterias que son capaces de
vivir de los respiro en el fondo del
océano gracias al calor que se genera
ahí pero el sol es nuestra principal
fuente de energía y cuando digo que
otras estrellas podrían haber estado
involucradas incluyendo estrellas
muertas que existieron hace millones de
años es porque los elementos más pesados
de los que estamos constituidos o que
están a nuestro alrededor en el medio
ambiente el carbono el oxígeno y podría
seguir y seguir casi todo lo que no sea
hidrógeno fue creado en reacciones de
fusión a partir de hidrógeno en el
interior de las estrellas así que
realmente estamos hecho de los restos de
estrellas y aquí estamos estamos en la
tierra la tierra es toda esa materia
condensada desde hace cuatro y medio
millones de años probablemente alguna
supernova cercana junto todo este polvo
que fue creado en una estrella anterior
y se condensó de esa manera y también
hasta la radiación tenemos la energía
del sol y una vez más esa energía viene
reacciones de fusión y es lo que está
fusionando a los elementos más ligeros
en elementos más pesados por lo que el
sol también está construyendo elementos
más pesados y esa energía llega hasta la
tierra hay organismos como las plantas
que son capaces de utilizar esa energía
para construir el material o la comida
podríamos decir que finalmente va a
llegar hasta nosotros y puede que estés
familiarizado con este proceso es la
fotosíntesis y vamos a entrar en más
detalle en el futuro y como la palabra
lo indica fotosíntesis es sintetizar
sustancias a partir de la luz y una cosa
que me gusta preguntar a las personas
cuando son expuestas por primera vez al
concepto de fotosíntesis es que bueno
podemos ver este pasto creciendo o
podemos ver este trigo creciendo o
podemos ver un árbol que crece pero de
dónde viene el material que usan para
crecer y la respuesta más común es que
de alguna manera de la tierra y si hay
algunos nutrientes que vienen de la
tierra pero en realidad todo es acerca
de la fijación del carbono y vas a
escuchar mucho sobre esto especialmente
cuando hablemos sobre el ciclo del
carbono
tenemos dióxido de carbono
principalmente en el aire así que
tenemos dióxido de carbono en el aire y
lo que la fotosíntesis permite a estas
plantas hacer es tomar el carbono en el
dióxido de carbono y formar enlaces con
el convertirlo de su forma gaseosa en
sus formas sólidas en moléculas de
glucosa y utilizar esa glucosa para
construir celulosa y la construcción de
almidón y cualquier otra cosa
así que toma estas moléculas de carbono
del aire y utiliza la energía del sol
para fijarlas para formar enlaces entre
los carbonos y con otras moléculas como
hemos dicho estamos hablando
principalmente de carbono e hidrógeno y
tenemos un poco de oxígeno también y son
capaces de formar estas estructuras
y esto se puede ir a otros organismos
vivos y lo estoy simplificando mucho
podría implicar a las bacterias y podría
implicar todo tipo de cosas y solo como
recordatorio la fotosíntesis no es solo
la luz y el dióxido de carbono también
involucra agua así que tenemos el
dióxido de carbono
co2 la luz del sol el agua y nutrientes
de la tierra y las plantas pueden crecer
y a partir de eso puedes tomar a estas
plantas que están tomando energía del
sol y construir cosas como el pan
o puedes tener otros animales que se
comen la hierba y luego las descomponen
a su manera con la ayuda de las
bacterias y luego reconstruir las
moléculas para formar una vaca o la
leche lo que estaba que está haciendo es
metabolizar esta hierba es capaz de
descomponer la es capaz de catalizar las
diversas moléculas en la hierba y
descomponer las en sus componentes
básicos que puedan después ser
utilizados para formar a la vaca o para
formar a la leche o cualquier otra cosa
y podrías preguntarte qué son estas
moléculas que descomponemos para después
reconstruir
bueno tenemos a los carbohidratos
los carbohidratos
y vas a ver a la mayoría de las
moléculas de las que estoy a punto de
hablar oa todas ellas las vas a ver
mencionadas en la parte posterior de un
empaque de algún alimento porque te dice
lo que contiene ese alimento qué es lo
que tu cuerpo va a metabolizar cuando se
come lo que hay dentro del empaque así
que los carbohidratos son los azúcares
simples como la glucosa o la fructosa o
podrían ser polímeros de estos azúcares
polisacáridos podrían ser almidones
compuestos por muchos muchos de estos
azúcares simples podríamos estar
hablando de lípidos ácidos grasos
podríamos estar hablando de colesterol
estas son estructuras esenciales y
también son esenciales para varias rutas
metabólicas dentro de todas o casi todas
las formas de vida o podrían ser
proteínas podrían ser
proteínas
compuestas de amino ácidos a veces las
personas dicen que la razón por la cual
deseamos a las proteínas es porque están
hechas de aminoácidos por lo que podrías
romper estas proteínas y obtener los
aminoácidos y luego reconstruir las en
nuevas proteínas y todas estas cosas las
proteínas y aminoácidos y todas estas
cosas se encuentran en los alimentos que
comemos que vamos a consumir y
metabolizar primero vamos a catalizar
los y descomponer los y luego vamos a
utilizar esos componentes básicos para
reconstruirlos y finalmente estos
proporcionan las estructuras que hacen
que nuestros cuerpos sean lo que son nos
permiten interactuar con nuestro entorno
y proporcionan energía
y la verdadera moneda molecular para esa
energía es una molécula llamada
atp esto es una molécula de atp justo
aquí
adenosina trifosfato
y la clave del atp la razón por la que
es la moneda energética molecular son
estos tres grupos fosfato tiene estos
tres grupos fosfato y tenemos todo un
vídeo acerca de esta molécula o toda una
serie de videos pero la clave principal
es que hay una gran cantidad de energía
especialmente en el último grupo fosfato
y esta energía en este enlace cuando el
grupo fosfato se separa pueden liberar
la energía del enlace para
proporcionarla a todo tipo de mecanismos
importantes para la vida incluyendo la
capacidad para metabolizar las cosas así
que el atp es la moneda energética en la
vida como la conocemos y en realidad es
una molécula muy interesante porque si
viéramos solo esta sección se ve como un
trozo de arn tiene una ribosa tiene la
adenina y un grupo fosfato y esta
molécula se puede utilizar para
construir cosas como arn o incluso adn
más allá de ser la moneda energética
molecular así que es divertido ver cómo
todas estas piezas encajan entre sí y la
forma en que se pueden dividir y ves
estos patrones una y otra vez en los
sistemas biológicos y estos sistemas
biológicos son formados por la
descomposición y su reconstrucción en
carbohidratos
los ácidos grasos colesterol y proteínas
o aminoácidos
así que mira a tu alrededor
observa tu día a día y mira las cosas
que estás consumiendo y verás este
patrón una y otra y otra vez y todo es
muy interesante porque al final del día
la energía proviene de las reacciones de
fusión en las estrellas y todos los
elementos pesados que te rodean o
incluso los elementos no tan pesados
todo el carbono el oxígeno todos los
elementos que no son hidrógeno han sido
creados en el interior de las estrellas
que podrían haber existido hace miles de
millones de años así que espero que esto
te haga sentir un poco más conectado al
universo